M it's
God it's
God Aramaic Hebrew Greek okay so what
what is uh do you believe we have theel
do do I believe that yeah that we that
we have the angil today Angel yeah yeah
okay so like it's in the Bible today
have you read it no no I don't some part
of the Bible you should read it man it's
good
excuse me you're not qualify to say
anything if you didn't read the whole
Bible ex them just a discussion so so
then um so you haven't read the Bible
just yet no I just read some part of the
Bible okay so are you interested in
it actually not only not only about the
religion I mean I'm interested about uh
Jewish religion christianism
but also the other Hinduism I mean all
the civilization I mean even before the
religion it's important and I do believe
in them absolutely so that as a were you
did you grow up in Islam uh actually yes
yes you grew up in Islam yeah okay so
you grew up in Islam and as a you're
you're an adult now and now you have an
interest in like all the religions what
they have to say yeah actually yes you
know why why because in the Quran all
the all the religion are mentioned I
mean you have Jesus you have moiz you
have ibraim and you have all the prophet
that actually in the in the Bible they
are also in the Quran so in any case
everybody every person that has read the
Quran it's like the same that he has
read the Bible and he has read the Torah
and he has read the the evangels and
because this is all these religion are
linked I mean this is just a process I
mean this is kind of what I would call
continuous
Improvement and you have some specific
rules that has been applied at the
beginning and then some of them has been
updated and at the end you have kind of
a final version that explain you how you
have to
behave and I think I think also we have
to respect each others I mean each let
me cut it let me cut in on this part cuz
you said something important like how
when you read the Quran you see that it
mentions the prophets right and this is
something that actually we hold dear as
like Christians obviously like we we
read the prophets right we read the
Torah what Moses taught we read the
entire what what is called the Tanakh
the old old testament which contains all
the prophets like David right with the
Psalms the zabor um Malachi and Isaiah
and all these different prophets right
Zechariah and then we read the gospel
with Jesus what's important to us is
that we see a consistent message right
that they're all teaching the same thing
and they interestingly enough they all
point to the Messiah they all point to
how the Messiah is going to come and
he's going to redeem us of our sins he's
going to Cle he's going to clean us up
right now when the Quran comes it's
supposed to be an addition to that right
and and it finishes it is what the Quran
talks about right but my problem is this
is that when I read the Quran it doesn't
match up with the previous scriptures
right like the previous scriptures like
it tells us that Jesus came came he's
the son of God who died for our sins
right and rose again on the third day
the Quran says no he's not the Son of
God what he said huh what he said he
says that whoever says that Jesus is the
son of Allah Allah's curse is is upon
him and they're deluded what the Quan
says about Jesus well that's what it
says it just says that he said good
things it's well this is what I was
saying no no no well he said good things
well let me Grant you let me Grant you
you only say good things no cuz this is
what I'm saying it's it's like this
would you say POS so let me let me ask
you this if you are your mother right
you love your mother you respect your
mother right would you say that it is
respectful of your mother if you when
you introduced her you said hey
everybody this is a good woman a good
friend of mine she's not my mother she's
not my mother but she's a good friend of
mine do you think that that's respectful
to your
mother uh if I said this if you said
she's not your mother but she's just a
good friend of yours a lovely woman
who's just a good friend no no because
this is my mother exactly so yeah even
though it's it's a nice thing to say
that she's lovely and a good friend but
it's not giving her due honor and
respect that she deserves cuz she's your
mother so yes the Quran says Jesus is a
prophet it says he's a messiah but it
says he's not the Son of God that's not
giv him the respect that he deserves cuz
that's who he is so that's what I'm
saying like when it IT denies him as the
son that's a disrespect to Jesus okay I
I would like to say something know the
actually I don't want to say that the
issue I mean this is something that is
quite logical for us because if you
consider that Mary is the mother of
Jesus and that Jesus is God that mean
that Mary is the mother of God even if
that we say that if Jesus died on the
cross that mean that God God God is dead
and died and I mean we I I respect each
religion I respect the the the writing
and I was born and I was educated with
Islam
but so the Islam is kind of an Heritage
for me but
then I learn a lot to understand what my
parents taught me to understand if this
was right or not so now with some
feedback I read a different uh book I
read a part of the of the Bible some
part of the Bible some part of the
Tor the Quran and so on and there is so
okay I can't understand that there is
some misunderstanding between the
different religion but I mean the
general message is the same it's not
though that's the point this and and
that's what I'm saying if the message
was the same then CL you got you got me
right like Islam could be is a is a true
is part of the True Religion but the
fact that it's not it has a different
message the message of the prophets is
the Messiah is going to come and save us
from our sins and if we don't believe in
the messiah's grace and his work then
we're going to be punished for our sins
and face Hellfire that's the message in
Islam it doesn't have that message right
it says that Jesus is not the Son of God
he did not die for your sins so that's a
completely opposite message you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah he said what
he said he said that um there is a God
that is what we called adimensional that
has no Dimension okay
and God has no time me right he's
eternal out out of the dimension out of
the time he's Eternal he's not he's not
bound by space or time right he's the
creator of everything yeah and we think
that God has not been created you know
he's uh he can't come into creation no
because if if what do you like if if God
wanted to could he if he wanted to take
on a form of a human and walk amongst us
if he wanted to if he want to take the
if he wanted to take on like come in
human form like come in human form I
don't know but is he do you believe he's
all powerful to do that I don't know
okay so that's fair enough no God can
can do whatever he want you know he can
do whatever he want because he is he has
the the power to do whatever he want
exctly so this is what we're saying
we're saying in Christianity we believe
that God because he he's all powerful
he's powerful enough to come in human
form and represent mankind walk amongst
us talk with us teach us
on our level right because we can't so
if you come in human form that mean that
originally is not a human exactly and
that's is what Christians teach
originally God is Not Human he's not he
he like what you said he's all powerful
he's not dimensional right he doesn't
you know he's not bound by space or time
or anything right he's outside of
creation but because he loved us he sees
that we have a problem we have a problem
of sin and we have to answer for our sin
understand right but we can't do it
ourselves so what he does is he comes
down in the form of man to represent
mankind on our behalf yeah but that this
does not answer that of the question
that maram gave Mary Mary gave birth to
Jesus well so Jesus at the beginning
when he was born he was what he was a
human or he was good or he was when he
died I mean I'm asking a question for
you because I don't know is a good
question so I don't know we point for
regarding this of course of course so so
you're asking basically what is Jesus's
nature before he's born like what was he
so this is the answer the Bible says
this because are you okay with this that
Mary has no
relation you have Jesus yeah yeah she's
a virgin yes yes she's a virgin right
she's a virgin so this and this is what
this is what we believe about the Jesus
is that Jesus existed right before his
human birth before he entered her womb
and took on a human body human form he's
God he existed was what we call the word
of God okay and this is what the Quran
says too right he's the word of God that
was cast down to Mary so even and the
spirit from him so even the Quran and
the Bible agree that Jesus is the word
of God that was with God right yeah the
spirit we said that she God insert the
spirit exactly right so that's what he
was before he took on a human body a
human form and was born through the
virgin
and so now we see that he has two
Natures we have he has that Spirit
nature right the divine nature and he
also has the human nature now that he's
born through Mary so he has two Natures
now United in the person of Christ and
so when we're we's walking around as
human he's also he's both God and man at
the same time and that's what we believe
right so and do you believe in Muhammad
I I don't believe that he's a prophet
and let me tell you why okay the reason
why I don't you believe you believe what
about Muhammad I believe he existed I
believe he's a real person and I do
believe in fact that he had an
experience like when he was in the cave
and the story when he's in the cave and
they believe that Gabriel came and first
gave told him to read read right or
recite I believe that he did have an
experience in the cave I I believe
something happened I just don't believe
it was from God I don't believe it was
an angel because when we look at what
happened with Muhammad and we compare it
to the prophets when they encounter
angels we never see for example like
Muhammad when he came out the cave he
was frightened and wanted to throw
himself off off the cliff he thought
that he was demon possessed he literally
said to his wife he said cover me cover
me because he thought that a demon or a
Jin had come upon him right and so he
wanted to end himself never do we see
when a prophet comes and he's
encountered with an angel we see the
angel brings them peace they say peace
I'm I'm I'm from the I'm from God and
immediately they're at peace they're not
afraid they're not frightened and they
don't mistake the angel for a demon so
now I would like to just to summarize
because it's complicated also for me to
like to argue in English this is not my
mother tongue I'm I'm French you do
you're doing good by the way you're it's
I mean
originally the message you know today we
have the Quran in Arabic I mean this is
the original message the original
language I mean people PA learn uh the
entire Quran since um like 14 U 14 um
1,4 400 years yeah and um I would like
to ask you now originally because Jesus
was speaking Armenian
Greek Armenian and and Greek and um and
also Hebrew Y and he was talking he
originally he was in in uh saying I mean
the message in uh in his language in
Aria Aran yeah and also in Jewish but
for the Jewish people Hebrew yeah so
yeah what's your question my question is
that why currently we do not have some
Bible some original Bible with the
correct message because I give you I
give you this is really important
because I never look we have we have my
brother here he's you know if you have
it you will you will see that God in
araman God the translation in
araman what is God what how do you say
God in araman well so let me answer the
first part and then I'll answer this
part no just this question you want this
one okay not the first one yeah okay
know all right so so no no no I got you
I got you so in arama it's
elaa not Allah but Ela a little
different right but it's just uh it's a
different it's just a different word
right but in in a specific language that
just means God okay that doesn't mean
it's talking about the same God what
matters is who are you saying Allah or
Allah is okay like if I if I'm saying a
statute is Allah I'm wrong right or if
I'm saying a statute or a tree is aha
I'm wrong I need to be talking about the
true God right that's what matters not
the word that I call him I definitely
agree and and so just to answer about
the languages so we actually do we have
the manuscripts we have the Scrolls in
Hebrew we have the Greek we have the
Aramaic we have that does the
translation is the correct one because
no because there is different
translation of the Bible and there's
different translations of of the Quran
no no we have different translation no
we have different translation of the of
the Quran like if you take in French you
have a specific organism that are in
charge of the validation of the
translation okay so in order to have a
Coran translated in French I mean the
official one the official I'm talking
about official certified there is some
specific organism that uh are in charge
of the translation and to validate and I
would like to say something about this
but there's a lot of different
translations that that say different
things impossible to translate for more
less the original message from Arabic
let me trying to understand what you're
saying you're saying it's impossible to
translate the Arabic into another
language it's quite complicated so then
so like compc so think about what you're
saying okay so if Arabic is so hard to
translate into another language then why
would God make the religion the true
religion based on Arabic a language
that's impossible to translate it for
people to get like I speak English this
means that I I can't receive The Message
of Islam you can no no no no no this is
not what I say you can
read it you can understand it but
sometimes you will make some confusion
because the meaning of one word can say
several things that uh the English or
French which are like quiet recent
languages not are not so you're saying
we got to we got to keep relying on the
Arab we no this is really new languages
I mean English and French is really newe
compared to Hebrew compared to Chinese
compar we do the same with the Bible
with the Bible and and speak to this
when it comes to the Bible we go to the
original languages to get the full
meaning right it's it's the same thing
and I understand what you're saying
right the the important thing that we're
talking about is so you understand Arion
Aramaic I know I I don't understand
Aramaic but I I can go pull it up and
look at dictionaries right you know so
I'm just just
English but but this is what I'm saying
is that the importance is the message
yeah yeah and if the message is not
consistent like if we have all the
prophet
saying one thing but then we have
another Prophet that comes and says
something different who would you go
with I mean I mean I will give you my my
my point of view regarding
this there was different type of people
Jewish Christian Muslim some that do not
believe and so on I mean everyone is
free to believe in something and I
definitely respect the people who does
not believe the same as me and I don't
want them to believe the same as I
believe this is really important for me
I mean I have a friend that actually
doesn't believe in anything I have
friend that believe in some statue I
don't know I have friend Christian I
have friend Jewish and so on and I
really respect and I just
trying what how why do they believe this
did they read this how what what is the
explanation and to exchange with them
but but not to exchange with them in
order to say Hey look look I am right
you are wrong or or the inverse I just
would like to to exchange to understand
because we will the truth it's
complicated to have the truth I mean we
are just simple human I mean we are just
simple human yeah me if I say I I have
the truth that mean that I know
everything you know the the the
knowledge that I have today they are
completely different from the knowledge
that I had like 10 years ago and this is
really important to to think that what
we believe today might be different of
that what we will believe but this is
what I want to say to this okay so but
what your the idea that you just
described is kind of like inclusive like
you're saying that everyone you know can
have a point of view that's equally
valid and stuff like that right what I'm
saying and I I understand trust me I
understand what you're saying but that's
not the quranic position the Quran says
absolutely not I know the Quran says
that Allah will accept no religion and
worldview except Islam
so you can't have another world view and
no I'm not judging I'm not in charge of
judging right already done that Allah
will judge but me I do not judge so then
as a Muslim you should want me to be a
Muslim Allah will decide who will Who is
good who is bad and so on I mean I'm not
in charge of this I'm just in charge of
living my life respecting people being
good with people and and and you know
the Judgment this is not my position I'm
not saying that you should judge what
I'm saying is that the Quran has a clear
position about with the others no no no
the Quran has the position that you have
to respect the other religion no it
doesn't no no no it definitely say that
brother I'm going to quote you a verse
this is chapter 98:6 it says Those Who
disbelieve among the people of the book
right the Jews and Christians and the
polytheists will have their Abode in
Hellfire they are the worst of creatures
it calls me as a Christian the worst of
creatures because I don't believe in
Islam that's not writing in in the Quran
yes what you said the r creators I mean
you want to see it man you you might
have the okay let let me know and I will
tell you the translation if I have it in
French what is the verse it's it's
chapter
98 might be able to pull it up chapter
98 I don't have internet okay I I do
um it's verse six
right here so let me put it in one
transl uh what is
this what is all
this and also you know regarding this
this is what I said that is really
important a things that is really
important also uh even if you read the
Quran the Bible or any other book is to
place the message in the context I mean
the so look it says indeed they who
disbelieve among the people of the
scripture and the polytheist will be in
the fire of hell and etal those are the
worst of creat okay I will check this I
will check this but I will tell you
something about about this kind of of
taking a vers and saying this this is
really important to place more context
right yeah to have context because the
Quran has been uh this is not one
message that came
once it took uh something like 25 years
yeah about 2 years and each time you had
a specific message in a specific context
sometimes it was for war sometimes it
was an answer some question there
context in any case the Quran is not a
message of um how do you
say
um of uh of hry you know it's just a
message that say okay there was
different people uh there is Jewish
there is Christian there's people who
disbelieve indeed indeed he said that
people who will disbelieve at the end
okay they might be in hell yeah that's
that's that's the results of the but not
just that we're the worst of creatures
bro yeah is that you think that's
respectful no actually actually what I
want to say that it's not disrespectful
this is it might be disrespectful
because in the Quran it considered that
Christian believe that God is a person
and he said in Quran that do not say
three do not say three I mean do not
talk about a trinity because I am the
only one and Jesus it he said that Jesus
and be careful also this because Jesus
all the things all all the senten in the
Quran about Jesus these are only
positive sentences but it's not though
okay I know that for you I know that for
you this is the opposite of of the bible
message I can
and this is my this is my point defitely
my my point is this is that cuz I know
that we have different views right I
know that my point is is that we we can
know if a view is true or not and this
is how the Quran gives us a test okay it
it the the the argument that it it makes
for itself is that it confirms and is in
line with what came before it right so
if I look at what came before it then
the Quran should never contradict what
came before it should be in perfect
alignment that's why I told you if it
does then it's false this is
not so what so it does no no no this is
not true
because what you say that mean that we
have only one
message well that's the point yeah no we
had similar message and if we have
similar message that's mean that the new
message correct something that has been
I mean uh how do you change CH yeah it's
called it in the previous message
because during some period of time uh
what what some people did so that mean
that we have to believe to the Torah and
that's all but you know what I mean I
know what you're saying thean never says
that the new message came and he said
for the basics he said that okay this is
more or less the same we have more or
less the same the basics I mean we have
a hell we have God we have uh heaven we
have the Angels no no we have the Angels
We Have The Creation not enough of the
Universe I mean you take 95 not are
these are surface level 19 90 95% of the
Torah of the Bible and trust me of the
of the of the Quran uh the message is
exactly the same so would you would you
say that would you say that a message if
if if they differ there was a few
difference let me ask you this let me
ask a few difference but that for you it
is important I definitely understand but
but if you're saying if this message
with minor differences there can be
differences in a message that don't go
against each other that don't contradict
right so what I'm at what I'm saying is
not that the message is different in a
way that um oh well you know different
times so different thing was said you
know this message was for this time
specifically that's not I'm talking
about I'm saying the overall main core
of the message is contradicted
understand by the Quran I understand I
can I cannot say the opposite because
this is true okay this is true so then
thean the message so this is the point
so this the point understand if if look
if all the prophets have the same core
message okay do you have some angry
about Islam or what angry about Islam
not angry but do you think that Islam is
trying to destroy christianism or
something like this but I can understand
I this is the reason why one it calls me
the worst of creatures for not believing
in ISL that's number one secondly it ALS
also tells them go and fight those who
do not believe in Allah nor the last day
or uh believe in what the messenger has
said among the people of the book the
Jews and the Christians until they pay
the jizer and feel themselves subdued
but believe me this is not the truth
what the say have you talk I mean this
is my first time in New York I just I I
I just arrived today uh uh and I'm
leaving
tomorrow I guess you met a lot of mus
people
yes all the same have the same message
about Jesus you know all the same you
always I'm sure that always heard some
positive things about christianism about
Jesus about the Bible it's not positive
If you deny who he is do you get it I
know I know no but you know that this is
what I told you before I can understand
that uh our position is different um
that the meaning is different I can
understand that um
the the difference between the Quran and
the Bible for you this is the most
important because he like he said
that I'm don't want to say you God or
our God but Jesus that you believe in
God he said that maybe it's not it's not
God and God is another than a than a
physical person and that's is really
strong for you I mean it's like
destroying the message of of this
christianism I definitely understand but
it's also the opposite I mean it's also
the opposite as the christianism said
that uh Jesus Is God and we do not
believe that Jesus is God so it's it's
in so they can't both they can't both be
true but it doesn't matter it does
matter no it doesn't matter because we
are we are just looking for the truth
and as I told you at the beginning and M
see based on this it depends on who goes
to heaven and hell brother and I and I
think and I think it will be my my my
last sentence because I have to go I
because I will have to go
we have different books okay we have
different religion we have different
Behavior every day but we are living
together in any case here in which is
why I want you to come to Christ man I'm
I'm from Switzerland I'm living in
Switzerland I'm from France uh I have
Christian friends Jewish friends people
who doesn't believe I like to talk about
religion civilization also in
Civilization Egyptian and so on this is
really interesting and the most
important is that okay we have different
thinking different uh message and so on
we are living together we have to
respect each others I respect Christian
I respect also what Christian believe
this is I I agree I I agree about to
believe and you believe about something
I believe about something some others
also and I think we have to respect each
others about this and then that's all
can I can I leave you with something too
sorry can I can I leave you with the
last message too yeah of course
definitely so so I understand what
you're saying right you personally
you're a cool dude you're chill I I I
would take you out to get a burger you
know what I'm saying I love you honestly
you're cool you know um and you have a
good mindset and this is what actually
you line up more with Jesus than
Muhammad you don't know that though but
Jesus says you know love your neighbor
as you love yourself and stuff like that
right and do a good unto others um and
but this is what he also says and this
is his main message he says that if you
do not believe that I am he if you do
not believe in the name of the son of
God then you face condemnation you face
God's judgment and that is his core
message yes we are to love and respect
each other right we can't say that we
love God and not love our neighbor
that's what Jesus teaches I can't say
that I love God but hate you and
disrespect you right I can't Jesus will
spit me out however it would be unloving
if I let you walk away you know thinking
that Jesus is a Kumbaya and is not
exclusive Jesus says if you don't
believe in him as the Son of God and in
his name then you don't have a savior
and you have to face God's Wrath that
because of your sins I believe in God I
mean for me not yet no I mean I believe
in God you believe in God but you're
you're you're I mean as you said before
if you said God
Allah God you know God for us this is uh
this is just a term Allah it's a name
you know I believe in God but I
definitely believe that God is AD
dimensional you said you don't have a
Bible uh I have just some part of the
Bible but I defin got to get your Bible
man that that that God is ADD
dimensional and not um not timing uh not
timing not bed in time and not
b and I mean that's what I believe um I
think that's all it was a pleasure give
me Aug man nice to meet you man thank
you for the conversation but it was
awesome and sorry my English is not you
did you did good man you did good didn't
you do good good guys you did good
SM oh my God logic
[Music]